la direction générale de la santé a
publié différentes recommandations pour
toute personne se rendant dans les pays
d'asie touchés par la grippe du poulet
au vietnam une sixième victime a été
enregistrée en thaïlande
le gouvernement semble avoir mis bien du
temps annoncé l'épidémie le détail ce 6
mai elle une sixième victime aujourd'hui
au vietnam un adolescent de 13 ans et
une première hier en thaïlande un homme
de 56 ans l'épidémie de grippe aviaire
ne cesse de s'étendre en asie et tout
particulièrement dans cinq pays le
vietnam et la thaïlande en premier lieu
mais aussi le japon la corée du sud et
le cambodge où les autorités viennent de
déclarer que 3000 poule a et est mort
dans un élevage près de phnom penh la
capitale
c'est la thaïlande qui paye le plus
lourd tribut au virus 7 millions de
volailles sont mortes ont été abattus
pour raisons sanitaires
l'industrie thaïlandaise est la plus
importante d'asie est aujourd'hui
gravement menacé pour autant les
recommandations du directeur général de
la santé à l'adresse des voyageurs qui
se rendraient en asie restent limités il
doit vraiment faire attention à ne pas
s'approcher d'animaux vivants notamment
les porcs et les volailles et lorsqu'ils
reviennent si ils ont des symptômes de
la grippe de la fièvre élevée de la toux
une difficultés pour respirer
il faut qu'ils consultent un médecin le
plus rapidement possible aucun vaccin
pour le moment ne protège contre le
virus de la grippe aviaire
l' oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé espère convaincre un industriel de
le développer
mais cela prendrait plusieurs mois et
constituerait un risque financier qu
aucun laboratoire privé n'était en
mesure de prendre